-Welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Tonight's the night!
Tonight is electric!
-Ooh!
-It's exciting!
♪♪
It's remarkable!
-Whoo!
♪♪
-It's memorable.
-Whoo!
♪♪
-It's unbeatable!
-Whoo!
♪♪
Jerry Seinfeld is here tonight
on "The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Léa Seydoux is
on "The Tonight Show" tonight.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
And music by Twice
on "The Tonight Show" tonight.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Not once.
-No, it's actually
their first time.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, really? Hm.
Guys, actually,
it is a big weekend for the NFL.
Everyone's talking about this.
For the first time
since he left for Tampa Bay,
Tom Brady is returning
to New England,
to face the Patriots.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Yeah.
-Whoo!
-Then, after the game,
he'll walk out of the stadium
while Patriots fans
cling to his legs
like little kids, like,
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Don't go, please.
Don't go, please."
Brady's been playing
for a long time.
Brady's so old,
when they do the coin toss,
he's going to pretend
he found it in the ref's ear.
[ Laughter ]
Brady's so old, he's the only
person on the field
who was able to get
the Pfizer booster.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Really?
-Amazing.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
He's so old, he calls peeing
the two-minute drill.
-Oh, what?!
-I don't know why.
I don't know what that means.
[ Laughter ]
Brady's been around
so long that,
during his career,
"The Sopranos" started,
ended, and came back.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's amazing.
Brady will return to his old
stadium to face the Patriots.
It's going to be an emotional
night for the fans
and they've already made
some signs for the game.
Check these out.
This one says...
[ Laughter ]
This next one says...
[ Boston accent ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, this one says...
[ Cheering and applause ]
A very emotional weekend.
Changing gears --
there's some big news
in the fight against COVID.
Researchers are developing
vaccine patches
that could replace shots.
A patch is perfect.
You literally get
vaxxed and waxed.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Krrkt!
-[ Mouths "Ow!" ]
-"Ow!"
-Seriously, a patch is great.
It's going to be fun
when everyone thinks
your eight-year-old
is trying to quit smoking.
[ Laughter ]
Now, when your crazy uncle
comes over for Thanksgiving,
you can just slap one
on the back of his neck.
It's like, "Good to see you,
Uncle, yeah.
Keep doing your research.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Going well?"
[ Applause ]
Meanwhile, drug maker Merck
announced today
that it's created the first pill
to treat COVID symptoms.
Yep, and, to get anti-vaxxers
to take it,
each pill's got a little picture
of a horse on it.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, as we speak,
Merck is throwing the pills
at people on Carnival Cruises
like it's Mardi Gras.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I saw that, this week,
former Vice President Mike Pence
was on a podcast and he said
that he's spoken to Trump
about a dozen times
since Biden took office.
[ Laughter ]
I'm surprised
they speak that much.
I mean, because, you know,
they both see the call coming in
and be like,
"Ugh, this freaking guy."
[ Laughter ]
"Hello."
But the real highlight
of the podcast came later.
Listen to what Pence said,
asked what his favorite
meal would be.
[ Laughter ]
Indiana pizza
and nonalcoholic beer.
I'd be ready for death, too,
I think.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Sounds about right.
I guess?
[ Cheering ]
I have a feeling Mike Pence's
bachelor party was
doing a jigsaw puzzle
on a Wednesday.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
the CEO and cofounder
of Whole Foods
is stepping down
after 41 years, yeah.
He finally saved up enough
to buy a beach house in Miami.
Or one sliced grapefruit
at Whole Foods.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, get this --
someone just paid $3,000
at an auction for underwear
that was worn by Michael Jordan.
-Ew.
-What?!
-You can hear more
about Jordan's underwear
in the new ESPN documentary
"The Last Pants."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a man in Texas
was pulled over
because he was driving
in a carpool lane
with a Halloween skeleton
in the passenger seat.
[ Laughter ]
And, to avoid the ticket,
the driver told the skeleton,
"Quick, switch seats with me.
Go!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show!
Guys, as I said earlier,
the biggest football game
of the season
is happening on Sunday night,
when Tom Brady
and the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
head to Foxborough
to take on his old team,
the New England Patriots.
Now, as you know, they end
every season with awards,
like, you know, Most Valuable
Player, stuff like that,
but they also give out awards
during the season.
Did you know that?
-No, I did not.
-Yeah.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ "Superlatives" ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
Our first player
from the Bucs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a rare award.
-Yeah, that's very rare.
-Yeah.
Next up from the Bucs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
He's like, "Hey!
He's wearing --"
-Wha-pssh!
Next up from the Patriots is
rookie quarterback...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Give me a Pence."
-"Give me another one.
I ain't driving."
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Bucs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?!
Wow. Wow.
Next up from the Patriots is...
[ Laughter ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That ain't gonna work."
[ Laughter ]
Next from the Patriots is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Patriots is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I didn't know that was going
to Broadway.
-Hope it goes to Broadway.
-And, finally, from the Bucs,
we have quarterback...
He was voted...
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you go.
Those are your NFL
"Superlatives."